у нещодавній резолюції Європарламенту
перед самітом України ЄС було наголошено
на тому що Україна має зокрема
забезпечити свободу слова вірність
принципам політичний плюралізм і за цими
дипломатичними словами стоять дуже чіткі
посили зокрема припиніть політичну
цензуру тому що воєнні обмеження не
мають нічого спільного з політичної
цензурою а закриття демократичних
українських каналів немає нічого
спільного з демократією припиніть
обнапатки на опозицію У нас є спільний
ворог Путін і Московська орда якщо ми
разом боремося то треба дійсно боротися
разом пліч-о-пліч припиніть обнулення
парламенту тому що такі в нас
парламентсько-президентська демократія а
не диктатура і на початку сесії Я хотіла
би наголосити Шкода що зараз тут немає
президента але насправді купа людей в
Україні вважає що у нас парламент
взагалі не працює і це зокрема через
рейдерство телеканалу рада на якому
висвітлюють конкретну одну особу
витрачаючи мільйони а мільйони замість
того щоб навіть у записі але показувати
діяльність парламентарів у нас також
відбувається
зникнення можливостей для парламенту
формувати порядок денний і це є
ненормальні речі і оскільки Зараз ми
маємо визначити пріоритети на наступну
сесію то найпершішим пріоритетом це є
Наші військовослужбовці яке скорочення
виплат і зарплат Які обмеження особливо
для тих хто на передовій і тих хто є у
госпіталях працює цілодобово ми тільки
на 11-му Місяці прийняли зміни до
законодавства щоби звільнити від
оподаткування і обмежень ввезення Дронів
і оптики 11 місяців блокувалося це
питання і ми просимо президента негайно
підписати ці законопроекти і ще не
сприймайте нашу позицію як опозиційність
якщо єдність то давайте працювати разом